hello everyone
great
you can see me daniel says loud and
clear
so excellent
okay well thanks guys for tuning in and
and
again for offering support for the
continued operation of my youtube
channel
so um
let's get going
it's good to see all of you
and so i've got a set of questions here
i'm i can see the
the live stream as well the live chat so
that's great
all right let's try this one what's an
effective way
to figure out how to
match your career with your temperament
how can you determine if a job is a good
fit or a terrible mistake let's start
with the first one what's a good way of
oh
what's an effective way to figure out
how to match your career with your
temperament
well
the first thing you do obviously that
you have to do is to
understand your temperament to some
degree and so the best way to deal with
that is to
get yourself assessed using a good big
five instrument there's many of them
online we're going to be setting up a
website within the next month that will
enable people to
do use a
tool that my student of mine colin de
young who's now a professor at the
university of minnesota
and i and some other co-authors
developed back in in i think it was 2007
called the big five aspect scale and it
breaks the big five down into ten
aspects and we'll have a version of that
online i hope by the end of july that's
the plan that will enable people to get
a
uh read of their temperament that will
tell them how extroverted they are how
high they are negative emotion or
neuroticism how agreeable how
conscientious and how open but it'll
break each of those
traits down into two aspects so
extroversion breaks into enthusiasm and
assertiveness neuroticism breaks into
withdrawal and
volatility
agreeableness breaks down into
politeness and compassion
conscientiousness into orderliness and
industrious and openness into openness
proper which is something like
creativity and interest in ideas
and so the first thing you have to know
is what your temperament is the second
thing you should probably know and we'll
probably add this functionality to the
system at some point is what your
intelligence level is what your iq is
because the
the higher your iq the better suited you
are for jobs whose demands change
rapidly and most so those are complex
jobs and simple jobs are the jobs where
you can learn something and then you can
run it as an algorithm you can just
repeat it over and over and those jobs
of course are becoming more and more
scarce
so
you need to know
what your temperament is and then you
need to know the temperamental demands
of the job now most jobs are are
mastered with a combination of
intelligence and conscientiousness
but the other temperamental factors play
a moderating role so for example
extroverted people tend to be
entertainer types and highly social and
so
if you're interested for example in
if you're extroverted then a career in
sales is something that you might
consider a career that involves a lot of
public communication and interaction
with groups whereas you're an introvert
you're going to work you're going to
want to work a lot more
um
you're going to be suited to work on in
a solitary manner a lot more
if you're agreeable you're going to be
suited for taking care of people if
you're disagreeable
then
you're a tough bargainer and a harsh
negotiator and and
litigators for example lawyers are are
often low in agreeableness
so if you're conscientious well that
tends to be a very good trait for any
kind of managerial and administrative
job and and for for for simpler jobs as
well uh it's a great predictor of
military prowess for example
um
if you're high in openness then you're
going to want a creative career and that
might make you an entrepreneur or a
musician or an artist of that or
something like that
that's often very very difficult to
monetize but um one of the funny things
about openness is that if you're high in
openness it's not that helpful at the
bottom of hierarchies because you're
basically expected at the bottom of most
hierarchies to act more or less like a
functionary but it becomes of critical
importance at the top of hierarchy so
it's a personality trait whose utility
can really kick in in the later stages
of your career because
in really complex positions where things
are changing dynamically you need to
have a high intelligence and you also
need to be creative
so how can you determine if a job is a
good fit or a terrible mistake ha
well
i would say you can tell if it's a
terrible mistake if you dread going
and also if you're working hard and
doing what you're supposed to and you're
not being rewarded for it or and there's
no chance for advancement so that those
are good reasons to
uh to leave
so
all right
truck plane says just wanted to tell you
that you're the first person to actually
make me read books i have a background
in math and engineering lots of formulas
and equations keep up your work well
good work truck plane there's some real
utility in reading books and i'm glad
that you found the the i'm glad that you
figured out why it's necessary to do
that so that's that's uh
that's
i'm very happy to hear that
oliver connor says it's definitely worth
doing the humanities it gives you a
skill set you can apply anywhere that's
actually worth elaborating on a little
bit because i do believe that
classical humanities education is at the
core of the proper university curriculum
and you might say well what's the
utility for example in studying
philosophy and literature but that's not
exactly the right way to look at it
the
utility of humanities uh education at
least in principle is that it teaches
you first of all how to be civilized and
educated so that you become aware of the
major cultural works that every educated
person needs to be aware of in order to
operate properly at a high level of
functionality in the world and what
you'll find is that as you get older and
you climb hierarchies of competence
that
broader and broader educational
familiarity is demanded of you but more
importantly education in the humanities
is designed to teach you how to think
and to speak and to formulate arguments
and because
what you're doing in complex positions
almost always involves
the identification of problems and their
articulation so that you can frame the
problem
then a description of a potential set of
solutions and then the communication of
those set of solutions to a wide variety
of people in a manner that can help them
obtain a consensus and work together
those set those skills are absolutely
crucial when you're doing anything
that's of real difficulty and so the
humanities education is extraordinarily
important as a as a consequence of that
um here's a question piaget's final
stage of morality was
he who can who he who can create the
rules would you please provide an
example of what that means
um yeah i can i can
it says uh
i'm having trouble i can't get the rest
of it but can you can you please provide
an example of what that means well
look at at
a lower stage of piagetian development
let's say where you're a child and
you've learned to play a game you're
going to determine morality on the basis
of
how well
you as a player adhere to the rules
now
at the point of development above that
you start to understand that well the
rules were actually a human creation in
in their original form
and that what that means is that when
it's necessary the rules can be adjusted
think about the harry potter series i
mean one of the things that
characterizes harry and his friends is
that
their and hermione is a really good
example of this is that they're
sufficiently disciplined i mean she
happens to be really disciplined
and are perfectly capable of following
the rules but also
make exceptions when that's necessary
and it's the fact that they can step
beyond the rules when that becomes
necessary that actually makes them the
heroes of the adventure because it's
very difficult to set up a situation
where
you can always act perfectly only by
following the rules because it's very
difficult to delineate out a rule set
that's sufficiently comprehensive so
it'll cover every eventuality so that's
the
that's the upshot on that
um women have a tendency to prefer bad
men higher in dark triad traits how come
the bible describes the mode of being as
associated with nice guy traits which
contradict that okay well i i take issue
with both elements of that actually i
don't believe that women do have a
tendency to prefer
bad men higher in dark triad traits they
may have a tendency to be more
erotically
attracted to men who are capable of
manifesting
dominance and aggression i think the the
evidence for that is relatively clear
and i don't think the bible at all just
describes the mode of being as
associated with nice guy traits
um i i don't know
that that may be how it's classically
taught for example because
christ is often presented especially in
more simple-minded very variants and i'm
not being um
pejorative about that precisely as the
ultimate in nice guys but i don't think
that that's true at all
that's a reasonable characterization at
all if you read the gospel accounts
because
he was someone who was certainly capable
of saying very very harsh things to
people and was also identified very
strongly as a figure who was capable of
using judgment and distinguishing
between what was positive and what was
negative and that capacity for judgment
is
um something quite different than than
than the mere nice guy compassion that
would be associated with high levels of
trade agreeableness so i think that
um
the the idea that the ideal that's put
forward in the biblical writings is
something like be harmless i think
that's a real misreading of the text and
uh i also think that it's it's it's
wrong because harmless and good are not
the same thing at all and in fact i
think
one of the best ways of characterizing
like a higher order morality and this is
something that nietzsche talked about a
fair bit is that
and and young as well with regards to
the idea of integration of the shadow is
that
someone who's moral has the capability
for violence and the capability for
aggression built in and at hand but is
also someone who's perfectly capable of
controlling that in a civilized manner
and i think that
you know i'm speaking off the cuff here
obviously but i think that
the the
the attraction that some women have for
the
for the sort of men who are more likely
to misbehave
uh to to act in a delinquent manner and
so forth is
partly
their
desire to be associated with men who
have the capacity for aggression now the
best
of all possible worlds is when that
capacity for aggression is civilized and
held under control but so i would say
that one of the things that men
should do as they mature is
transform themselves into monsters but
also become civilized at the same time
and that's exactly what you see in
stories like beauty and the beast where
the the
the the ideal man starts out as a beast
and ends up civilized he doesn't start
out as a milkshaw wimp sort of character
who you know who who poses no threat to
anyone and then becomes the hero that
isn't how it works although there are
stories of that kind of development
so
um which is the most accessible of carl
jung's books
oh well i wouldn't say any of them are
particularly accessible although modern
man in search of a soul is probably a
good one to start with that's modern man
in search of this of of of a soul i
think modern man in search of his soul
anyways
it's modern man in search of a soul i
believe it's short and it's to the point
and and so that's a good introduction
which has been the most impactful to me
probably ion a i
o n which is the second volume the
second
volume of
volume nine of the collected works which
is an absolutely amazing terrifying book
which describes it actually it it
actually it contains some of jung's
writings on the psychology of astrology
which are actually quite interesting
because he regarded astrology as a
millennia
long
as millennia-long fantasizing on the
part of the collective human imagination
and and spent a lot of time in analyzing
the content of that you might think
about it as a dream that was projected
out into the cosmos
so
what are your personal strategies for
consuming the news
well you know it's funny for years i
haven't watched television news for
example and i don't read newspapers very
often either i i try to actually limit
my exposure to the news
i read the economist i used to read
harper's magazine i used to read um
the uh
um atlantic monthly as well i thought
they were good periodicals although i
think both of them have collapsed quite
precipitously in recent years harper's
maybe not so much
how do i walk the line between wanting
to be informed while avoiding the danger
of cluttering your mind well the
economist helps with that
i think it's actually gone downhill to
some degree over recent years as well
but i definitely tell my clinical
clients very frequently especially if
they're depressed and feeling
overwhelmed to limit their exposure to
to daily news particularly because if
something's only relevant the day that
it's published you could make the case
that it's not relevant at all which is
part of the reason why i like the
economist because it only comes out
every week or two weeks depending on
your subscription and so it can only
cover things that have enough importance
to to be relevant over a time frame that
exceeds a day
so
all right so let's see what we've got in
the live stream here
how do we revive interest in the good
mother archetype
well that's a good question um
i think it's a good question in part
because it isn't really obvious to me
that
young women in our society are told the
truth about what their lives are likely
to be like you know they're they're
they're
they're taught
both explicitly and implicitly
that their primary interest will be in
the pursuit of a dynamic career
and there's some real problems with that
the first is that
the proportion of people who will have a
dynamic career
in the technical sense is actually quite
low
because most people have jobs and not
careers and even in those jobs that
might be regarded as careers
much of the work that's done is job-like
i mean the reason that people pay you to
have a job is often because you're
required to do things that you wouldn't
do if you weren't being paid
and so
we we
we glamorize the role of career
and confuse jobs with careers and assume
that most people are going to end up
with high-end careers and then we also
assume
that most people
even those who are qualified to have
high-end careers are actually the sort
of people who would like to have
high-end careers if they could and
that's also often not true so for
example i've worked very intensely with
a large population of female lawyers
usually
see usually partners at large law firms
very very successful women usually very
attractive very intelligent
extraordinarily conscientious
and the sort of people who were
outstanding in high school and then
outstanding as undergraduates and then
aced law school and then did their
articling perfectly and then
uh became associates and then eventually
entered the partner stream in a large
law firm and then became partners and a
huge proportion of them wake up around
30 somewhere between 30 and 32 and
notice their 65-hour days and the
incredibly competitive environment that
they happen to be in and the fact that
the demands of their career are only
going to accelerate as they move forward
i mean they're going to make a lot of
money but the the demands on their time
of their career only going to accelerate
as they move forward
and
decide quite rapidly that that's maybe
not what they want and the reason for
that is they also would like to have a
life they'd like to have a relationship
that they could attend to and they'd
like to have children
and the truth of the simple truth of the
matter is is that it's very very
difficult
to have a truly high-end career and have
an important relationship and have
children especially if there are two of
you trying to pursue that at the same
time it's very difficult and it's
difficult to have a high-end career
period and it's also difficult to have a
fully functional family trying to
combine those sorts of things makes
people who are
i mean i've seen people do it but man
they they push themselves right to their
limits and they usually have limits that
exceed the limits of typical people
so one of the things we could do for
example to revive interest in the good
mother archetype is to stop telling lies
to young women about what their life is
likely to be like because my experience
has been and you might think i'm
old-fashioned although i don't really
think i am by the way
i think i'm actually quite current and i
pay a lot of attention to what's going
on around me and my experience has been
overwhelmingly that high caliber women
decide in their 30s that relationship
and family is the most important thing
in their life and i think the reason
that the fact that major law firms for
example have a really difficult time
holding on to their high performing
women even though they bend over
backwards to do that is actually an
indication of exactly that and this
notion that it's a glass ceiling in some
sense that are stopping women from
advancing up the corporate ladder i
believe to be a truly erroneous as well
as dangerous and i i don't think there's
real any really any evidence to support
that
so
all right fraser burns says highly
creative stupendously low in
conscientiousness am i doomed um no
you're not doomed and i think that
openness and conscientiousness are often
at odds with one another it isn't
obvious to me how someone can easily be
highly creative and orderly for example
because to be creative means to make
some disorder in the intermediary stages
of being a creative person
i would say also that many creative
enterprises
are not the sort of thing that anybody
who was sensible from the perspective of
being conscientious conscientious would
ever pursue like the lifestyle of a
musician for example i would say though
that if you're
low in conscientiousness and really high
in openness high in creativity is that
you're going to have you're going to be
able to
generate a lot of creative ideas but
you're going to have a hard time
implementing them you won't have the
follow through and you may have to
really learn to discipline yourself and
i would say
the simplest way to start disciplining
yourself is to use something like google
calendar to establish a schedule and
and stick to the damn thing like train
yourself to get up at the same time
train yourself to eat at the same time
train yourself to follow a schedule so
that you undertake the tasks that you
need to undertake each week on a regular
basis but but you can leave in that a
little bit so that it doesn't become
intolerable by using the schedule to
design days that you would want to have
instead of just days that you should
have like a schedule doesn't have to be
a tyrant
the proper use of a schedule enables you
to have the maximum amount of freedom
while also maintaining the
responsibility necessary to stop your
life from auguring into the ground
so
if you're high in openness and and in
all likelihood you're fairly intelligent
if that happens to be the case and
you're low in conscientiousness you
might be able to get the best of both
worlds by learning to discipline
yourself but it's going to be a
step-by-step process and i would also
say do something like the future
authoring program from selfauthoring.com
and even if you do it badly because
one of the things that will help you
discipline yourself is to have a plan
and a plan is this is the something that
all of you who are listening should know
it's like i really recommend doing that
future authoring program because
you you will not get what you want
unless you figure out what it is you
won't be of as much to use to yourself
and to the broader world unless you
develop a vision and implement it and
and the best way to do that is to do it
seriously and
and one of the best ways to do something
seriously is to write about it so
um
my goal is to be married and on my way
to to starting a family within five
years is this a legitimate goal to have
for myself well absolutely i mean
absolutely
all of these things can be made
conscious i mean you know we have this
romantic
belief i suppose that
um if you open yourself up to
opportunity then it will ferret you out
and your dreams will come true but
that's kind of a naive way of looking at
the world and it's much more likely to
be the case that if you aim at something
and and you aim carefully and
thoughtfully that you're
that you will orient yourself in a
manner that makes you
aware of the opportunities that will
arise that will put you in that
direction that's actually how your
perceptual systems work and so part of
the reason that it's so useful to orient
yourself with regards to a specific aim
is that your perceptual systems then
turn on to tell you what's going to
facilitate your movement forward and
also what's going to get in the way
now you don't want to be too
single-minded about it because you can
get obsessive and you also want to
maintain enough flexibility in your aim
so that you can change them when
necessary but
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
deciding not only
you know over what period of or during
what time frame you might want to get
married and when you might want to have
children but what kind of partner you
want to have and what what sort of
interests you would like to share with
them and to really specify your life
because it's much more likely that it's
going to be turn out in a positive
manner for you and everybody else if you
put some intelligent thought into it
just like it's the case that almost
everything is likely to turn out better
if you if you do that
do you suggest homeschooling with the
state public schools are currently in
no i don't suggest it i think
homeschooling is an incredibly difficult
thing to pull off properly and
i think that
there i think that the number of people
who would do it badly far exceeds the
number of people who would do it well
having said that it's not like i think
it's wrong and it's also not like i
think that there isn't increasing reason
for parents to consider that because i
do actually think there's increasing
reason for parents to consider that
because the post-modern postmodern
neo-marxists have got their claws into
the education system and i think they're
doing everything they can and you can
certainly see that in in canada in
ontario where the
elementary teachers federation of
ontario has published their their their
their
i think it's guideline curriculum it's
something like that
that's basically a blueprint for
transforming kids into social justice
oriented individuals from kindergarten
through grade eight so it's not
surprising that people want to do that
so
um but i think that
parental rights trump state rights in
relationship to children and it has to
be that way even though there's lots of
bad parents
the the thing about bad parents is that
the state as parent is worse it's not
that there are no bad parents but to
assume that the state is going to be a
better parent on average than parents
who actually love their children is a
very bad idea
so
why is jordan peterson's webcam a
thousand times better than all of my
favorite youtube
youtubers with millions of subscribers
because my son julian who helps me with
technical matters bought a dlsml camera
dlsr camera for me that happens to work
extremely well except the battery runs
out about every hour and 15 minutes and
i have to change it so
um and i think there's a
there's
it would be nice if i could actually
plug it in with an adapter but i think
that that changes the category of camera
to video camera and then there's tax
implications or something like that so i
have the high quality camera and i have
to put up with the fact that the battery
dies so
um
how do i plan to buffer myself from the
deteriorating deteriorating side effect
of success
that's a really good question actually
i can tell you a bunch of answers to
that i mean the first is is that i have
a sensible family
a son and a daughter and and soon to be
a son-in-law and a daughter-in-law as
well who um i like and who like me and
we get along really well and they're
really sensible people and so they help
keep me
my feet nailed to the ground and so does
my wife because my wife is also an
extremely sensible person and someone i
really deeply trust and i'm also
fortunate in that i have parents who who
play that role with me as well and a
sister and a brother-in-law um
and and my brother as well who
helped me
stay
attuned to
the potential dangers
that this widespread public exposure
might otherwise produce but so but the
other
issue so there's that i have advisors
let's say who are on my side who tell me
the truth and and we discuss
what i'm doing all the time to make sure
that it's staying more or less on track
the other thing too is though you know
i'm not exactly a young man anymore i'm
55 and
um i think a lot of the
detrimental elements of widespread
public exposure
are
things that would have been a lot more
harmful or that are a lot more harmful
to people when they're younger there's
just a lot of things about being in the
public eye that don't have the same
cachet to me
that they might have when i was a
younger person or that they would have
to a younger person and i guess i would
also say that i don't really believe
that i'm the sort of person to let
and i'm not trying to put myself on a
higher moral plane or anything with this
comment but i don't think i'm the kind
of person to let the sort of thing
that's happened
over the last
year or so really go to my head and i
think part of the reason for that is
that i have a fairly pronounced
depressive temperament and so that i can
see the negative side of myself with
with plenty painful clarity and i'm i'm
also more concerned about
the
possibility of making a catastrophic
mistake as i present myself publicly
than i am in
what clambering up some
power ladder i suppose and elevating
myself to a position at the top i'm just
not that interested in that
and so
i think and i'm i'm also i think fairly
aware of the dangers of
of
well let's say fame to the degree that
that's what's occurred to me um
i i know the downside of that and it
isn't something that i'm interested in
and i'm actually i know it's a strange
thing but
to think about but i'm actually also
rather private person and and um
although i'm i can't keep my mouth shut
obviously and i'm i'm very talkative
that's from being very high in openness
even more than being high in
extroversion i think
and uh
there isn't anything that comes along
with the dark side of fame let's say
that i would find particularly
attractive
you know i'm not really interested in
partying
endlessly although i had my
time doing that when i was young i'm
certainly not interested in um
whatever additional attractiveness to to
females that my
more well-known
the fact that i'm more my well-known
might provide to me that that just
doesn't interest me at all i'm very
happy in my marriage and also
very
aware of
the catastrophes that lie
in directions of that sort of temptation
so
um but but i also
i think of all those explanations the
one that's most relevant is
my
see i know that i'm walking a tightrope
in some sense and that it would be very
easy for me to make the kind of error
that would sink me
and i know that there are many people
who don't approve of what i'm doing who
would be very happy about that and so i
think also living in a
somewhat constant state of existential
terror about the probability that this
debt house of cards could collapse is
also something that keeps me oriented
in the humble direction and
dwelling on this a little bit but it
really is an interesting question
i am also
i believe i also have trained myself so
that i orient myself mostly to
considering what i'm doing wrong and
what i could be doing better than what
i'm doing right
and so i'm
always on the lookout in all of the
presentations i make for
where i didn't say things as clearly as
i might have and where i could have
improved my delivery and so
concentrating on
where what i have yet to attain is also
a good way of keeping whatever
ego boost there might be in
more widespread public recognition under
control having said that i'm very it's
not like i'm ungrateful
for the fact that all this has happened
it's actually an amazing thrill i mean
things happen to me all the time that
are that are so overwhelmingly positive
that i can't believe it so last night
for example i went to this restaurant
called the keg
and i go there because i have a lot of
food allergies and they're actually very
careful with people who have food
allergies
and the waiter showed us to the table
and he knew who i was and he said that
he had been watching my videos and that
he had had
four promotions i think that's what he
said no he said yeah four promotions in
the last four months at the keg
and the reason for that was that he had
been watching my lectures and decided
that he was going to adopt a more
responsible attitude as an employee and
also
you know start pushing the development
of his career at this at this restaurant
and that it worked out brilliantly and
like it was so positive because
you know it would you know i thought
about it as a true victory on his part
because he took the situation that he
was actually in so a real situation and
decided that he was going to maximize
the opportunity that was there for him
and you know there's nothing about that
that's negative it's all positive and
it's a personal story and he shared it
with me and i had some small role in
bringing that about and like that's just
an absolute thrill as far as i'm
concerned like every time someone writes
me and says
um
i've been watching your videos and i've
just decided to sort out my life and to
aim higher and that's working it's just
like it's such a thrill for me to be
able to provide that service for
hundreds of thousands of people it's
like
it's a
it's an unbelievable privilege and i
hope i can figure out how to do it
better and better as i get more and more
practiced at it i mean that's really the
aim and with my colleagues uh daniel
higgins for example i have two business
partner daniel higgins and and robert
peel peel was my um
graduate advisor at mcgill and daniel
higgins
was one of my graduate students at
harvard and we've been working on making
psychological interventions accessible
to people for about 20 years so they
helped me develop the self-authoring
suite for to for example we have a whole
host of
psychological tools
in development including a future
authoring program for high school
students that we want to bring to the
broader general public and so this
public exposure also gives me the
opportunity to
to
make what i know as a clinical
psychologist and as someone with some
specialization in technology especially
through my partnerships make that
accessible to
perhaps millions of people i mean
god that's that's just an amazing
opportunity and so
someone asks how do you find
the self-authoring autobiography
outline well you go to selfauthoring.com
it's available there
let's see
someone annette adler says i have also
done better in a lot of things due to
your kicks in the ass yeah well i mean
that's great annette i'm thrilled to
hear that um
see part of it you see the thing about
disciplining someone let's say is that
when you and i see this very clearly
when i'm talking to young people is that
i'm really on the side of the person
that
wants
to do something positive with their life
to make their own life better because i
think that's where you should start you
should start by making maximizing the
quality of your own life that's not a
selfish thing or if it is it's the right
kind of selfishness and that you should
figure out how to do that in a way
that's of benefit to your friends and
your family and your community and you
should take that deadly seriously and
the reason you should do that is because
that just makes life better for everyone
and it
reduces a fair bit of the misery that
would otherwise be part and parcel of
life and it makes everything function
smoothly and one of the things i'm
really curious about is what the world
would be like if everybody decided to do
that because human beings are really
remarkable creatures and we hobble
ourselves very badly with deception and
resentment and revenge and the desire to
make things worse and arrogance and all
those
all those sins let's say that that that
make us deviate from our true path and
our true path should be something like
imagine the noblest aim that you can
conceptualize and then sacrifice your
life to attempting to attain it and
there's nothing in that that isn't good
for everyone and so apart from the fact
that it requires a lot of responsibility
i just can't see why everyone wouldn't
do that and when i'm talking to young
people and you know shaking my finger
and saying you know grow the hell up and
get mature and take on some
responsibility i'm not saying that
because i'm an enemy of the person i'm
saying it because i'm the best friend of
the part of them that would really like
to walk in the light and and it's an
invitation to walk in the light and and
it would be remarkable this is what we
need to do as far as i'm concerned
not only in the west but in the world at
large but maybe in the west first is we
have to
consciously decide that we're going to
do everything we can as individuals to
walk in the light and to regard that as
a noble and heroic endeavor and to make
that first and foremost in our lives and
that's what we should be educating young
people to do and they can do that and so
i have dozens of people writing to me
and and talking to me all the time who
are saying the same thing they're saying
look i've really been trying to get my
act together over the last six months
i've been trying not to lie
which is slightly different than trying
to tell the truth right it's a more
humble goal to not lie because you can
tell when you're lying but you can't
necessarily tell when you're telling the
truth and i i've been coming up with a
plan and i've been trying to discipline
myself and i've been cleaning up my room
which is like a nice humble act that
that involves transforming chaos into
order and they write and say god things
are just working out way better for me
it's like whoa do it man that's just
you you keep that up for 15 years and
you'll be unbeatable and that's what we
should be convincing young people to be
is to be unbeatable and not because
that's what they should do or because
they're bad if they don't but because
there's nothing better you can possibly
do with your limited and
your limited and suffering bound life
than to aim high and and sacrifice
yourself to the attainment of those
goals so that's uh
being a highly creative woman i find
myself fearful that having kids will be
spiritual suicide hindering my endeavors
but i also don't want to have an
unfulfilled life can i have a full life
without kids
well yes i i suspect you can although
it's risky maddie because it's really
important for people to have kids
because the thing is is that you get
older than 40. and our culture is kind
of dopey in that regards it's
underdeveloped we live as if
we live as if we we only exist when
we're young and we don't it's like what
are you going to do
from the ages of say 45 to 90 or 95. you
need a family around you you need to see
your children grow you need to have
grandchildren it's a major part maybe
the most important part of the last half
of life
now you said being a highly creative
woman i find myself fearful that having
kids will be spiritual suicide well
that's the part of your question that i
would really address because i would say
well don't let them be spiritual suicide
you know it may be that there's a
certain amount of time that you need to
take away from the kids and then this is
the case for parents in general um so
that you can pursue your own creative
endeavors it's children do not have to
devour your life in fact if you let them
devour your life then you'll hate them
and you'll mistreat them and so what you
want to do is to set yourself up so that
you can have children and have a life
and that's better for the children and
it's better for you like children can be
taught encouraged to spend a fair bit of
time not when they're infants obviously
but to
spend a fair bit of time amusing
themselves that's especially the case if
you have more than one child because
they'll mutually amuse one another it's
actually easier in some ways to have
more than one child because with one
child you're constantly amusing the
child but with two or three then they're
off in their little you know club
especially if you can stop them from
developing sibling rivalry that's too
intense and they can monitor themselves
so the trick is if you're a highly
creative woman is be disagreeable enough
so that you can carve yourself out your
own space so that you don't come to
resent your children you're afraid of
that you're afraid that it looks like
you're afraid that if you
if you give yourself to children
there'll be nothing left for you and um
you know that can happen if you have
children who have terrible health
problems for example but you can't
protect yourself against those
eventualities in life anyways but i
would say your best bet is to be a more
selfish mother and believe me i've had
more clients who were ruined by mothers
who were too unselfish than i've had
clients who were ruined by mothers who
were too selfish
so
um you need to be there when the kids
need you but you shouldn't be there any
more than is necessary
so
let's
see adam watts says i feared having kids
for the same reason i'm a full-time pro
artist you make your own normal said my
therapist jp is speaking the truth yeah
well that's
that's the thing you know don't be
thinking that you can't
organize your life when you have
children the thing about modern people
is that they're terrified of children
they in this because they think they
regard children as if they're miniature
tyrants and they can be of course
because anyone will tyrannize over you
if you allow them to
perhaps not anyone but virtually anyone
why not regulate your children's
behavior i wrote a chapter in my new
book called
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them and that's like
really serious advice is like if you
allow your children to conduct
themselves around you in a manner that
makes you dislike them if you're being
honest if you're paying attention to the
shadow side of yourself that can be
aggressive and destructive
then
then you're if you allow your children
to do things that make you dislike them
then they're going to
their having children is going to mess
up your life but you don't have to do
that you're actually you actually have a
tremendous amount of control over the
quality of your relationship with your
children and also the manner in which
you choose to just disperse your time
and i mean you're
you've got
if you're willing to
think it through and be clear
you can be in charge of your household
the children don't have to be in charge
and it's not good for them to be in
charge anyways so
people are afraid of children and it's
too bad because children are absolutely
wonderful i mean you have to
be careful with them and they get tired
and they get hungry and they get hot and
and they don't have an attention span
that's as long as an adult who has a
long attention span but
they're great company and they're
unbelievably comical and they love you
and like they they give back far more
than they take if you have an ounce of
sense when you're dealing with them so
yeah so so don't be afraid of children
man
you're you're the adult for god's sake
you've got the upper hand and and if you
have a partner you can rely on well then
you know you can both
decide how it is that you're going to
run your household so that you're
actually thrilled to death that you have
kids and that you have a life
so
all right let's see
when am i appearing on h3h3
november i believe november 3rd
so i'm looking forward to that
um
let's see
how do you help someone with borderline
personality disorder that's matthew
dodson
matthew you know i'd like to answer that
question but it's so damn complicated
that i don't think i can manage it um so
instead of doing a bad job even though
that's a very interesting question i'm
afraid i'm going to skip that
um let's look back at the pigeonhole
panel here
um
do you consist
some people have criticized my portrayal
of post-modernism in what ways would you
claim you were fair or unfair in your
assessment of its core principles
well um
i've done my best to to
give it an even-handed assessment
um and
i think i'm unfair in that any
rather truncated criticism of a large
body of thought is liable to clip a few
corners
but
i would say that
i'm attempting to provide a snapshot a
relatively accurate but low resolution
snapshot of a certain kind of war id on
a war of ideas that's currently going on
in our culture and that's primarily
centered in the universities and i don't
think my assessment of post-modernism
and its relationship with neo-marxism is
unfair in the least in fact i think that
the danger that's presented by
that combination of ideological
uh
of ideological presumptions is more
dangerous than people are currently
aware of and that it poses a larger
threat to the integrity of our culture
than
i've currently stated it's more
widespread than i thought for example
when i first started
um speaking out against
postmodernism and neo-marxism i didn't
realize for example that the law schools
had turned into
it had turned into training grounds for
social justice activists i didn't
realize that the legal system the legal
training system had become corrupt
perhaps not to the same degrees as say
the faculties of education or social
work but certainly a long ways down that
road and so
i think i do believe that postmodernism
is an intellectually bankrupt school of
thought and i believe that its alliance
with neo-marxism borders on malevolent
and it may even go past the border into
actual malevolence because i don't
understand how anybody with an inkling
of historical sense can take a look at
the 20th century and then dare put
forward ideas that are derived from
marxism as a as a as a treatment for any
of society's hypothetical um
disorders and it's not to say that i
don't believe that there are
that there are errors in in in western
culture say
for for whatever that's worth i mean
individuals make moral errors all the
time and groups make moral errors and
cultures make moral errors
that isn't the issue the issue is
how are we doing compared to any
reasonable alternatives
what makes you think that
it's it's appropriate to compare the
performance of western societies for
example to some hypothetical utopia of
your own fictional imagining especially
when we've seen what sort of utopias
have emerged out of
out of out of such imaginings and um
what is it that you are offering people
as a concrete alternative and all i see
in post-modernism is destruction and
nihilism and all i see in neo-marxism is
historical ignorance malevolence and
um
misdiagnosis well and in gratitude and
arrogance i mean the the list goes on
and on so i don't feel that i've
misrepresented the postmodernists in the
least and i fi i regard like i've read a
fair bit of foucault less of darada but
enough to get a pretty good sense of
what he's on about like foucault is
readable but more or less uh obvious as
far as i'm concerned and so he's a third
rate thinker and darada is just a
troublemaker as far as i'm concerned
although a very brilliant one and the
idea that the postmodernist had that
there's an infinite number of ways of
interpreting any set of
data let's say that actually happens to
be a true
observation and a very problematic one
which is partly why it's it's so
difficult for example to evolve a system
that can
that can visually perceive the world and
why about half our brain is devoted
towards that it's it's definitely the
case that
coming up with a viable interpretation
of the world is a very difficult process
but
but that's about as far as the validity
of the post-modernist claims go after
that it's like well
yes there's a very large number of
potential interpretations of the world
but there's a very small number of
actually viable interpretations and
that's really what's relevant and
viability is constrained by all sorts of
of uh
what would you call them well let's call
them constraints yes
you you have to
interpret the world in a manner that's
commensurate with
the minimization of your own intolerable
suffering that puts
very tight constraints on which
interpretations you're allowed to bring
forward you have to do that in a manner
that's iterable and repeatable across
time you have to do that in a way that
isn't too objectionable to other people
or even better in a manner that what
makes them want to cooperate and compete
with you so that you know a rising tide
lifts all boats there's immense
constraints on
organizing your perceptions in a manner
that is
simultaneously individually and socially
highly functional and the postmodernists
just just don't grapple with that at all
they and and they're they're
biologically ignorant beyond belief and
proud of that fact anyways as you can
tell i can hardly say enough things that
aren't good about post-modern
neo-marxists there's there's apart from
the fact that they got the initial
observation right which is that there's
a very there's almost an infinite number
of ways of interpreting a finite set of
data everything else they've done is not
only intellectually bankrupt it's also
morally reprehensible and i think
they're corrupting our culture and i
think they're they're they're hurting
young people and they're hurting them as
well by
getting them to pay for being hurt which
is really quite a malevolent um
enterprise so i've got no
what would you call i have absolutely no
regrets
about going after the post-modern
neo-marxists as hard as i possibly can
and i'm certainly not done doing so so
one of the things that's going to happen
for example in the next month or so
i've been working with a programmer
who's who's volunteered his services and
has already produced this he's produced
a website that enables people to enter
text that will then classify the text as
postmodern or non-postmodern and so
you'll be able to enter course
descriptions from universities
the course description the professor's
name the discipline and the university
it will tell you the degree to which the
description is post-modern and then you
can decide for yourself whether you want
to take that and become a social justice
warrior if that's what you think your
education should be about or if you
should avoid that like the plague that
it truly is and so my goal if i had to
set a personal goal and this is the sort
of thing maybe that you guys are helping
me do with my continued support on
patreon is that i'd like to knock
enrollment in the post-modern
disciplines down by 75 over the next
five years
i think that
i think i'm thinking about it from the
perspective of of non-violent warfare
it's that serious to me and that this
would be equivalent to cutting off the
supply chain it's like the the the
post-modernists need a continual influx
of young impressionable minds in order
to continue their propagandistic and
society devouring efforts and i'm going
to do absolutely everything i can to cut
that supply chain off at the source
hopefully and and reduce their
enrollment to the zero that would match
their citation rate for their
publications
so
would i end my career as an academic in
order to enter politics as a candidate
for mp under andrew scheer's leadership
uh no
i don't think i would do that i mean i
thought for a while
i thought at one point of running for
the leadership of the liberal party in
canada and then i thought at another
point in running for the leadership of
the conservative party
but both times i decided that what i was
doing as a
academic and i would say as someone
who's a phyllis philosophy
a philosopher a philosophy and science
jesus it's been a long day guys i'm i'm
starting to forget how to talk
as a philosophically and scientifically
minded psychologist
was more useful than anything i could
likely do practically in the political
realm and i haven't seen any reason to
change that opinion
as a consequence of the events of the
last eight months or so and so although
i've always been interested in
politics as a potential career route
every time the opportunity has arisen
and i've had to make a choice between
continuing what i've been doing and
pursuing a political pathway i've always
decided to continue doing what i am
doing and i think that's probably what i
will continue to do i actually think i
can have more influence
doing what i'm doing than i could by
doing anything else and that's partly
because i suppose if i thought there was
anything else i could be doing that was
more useful i'd be doing that instead
so
that's the answer to that
um
what is the role of art in a healthy
culture is post-modernism as destructive
in this domain as in politics well let
let's that's michael bamford well what's
the role of art in a healthy culture
well the artists articulate the the
artists are the people who first
articulate the unknown
and so the role of artists in a healthy
culture is to bring to public awareness
elements of being that have not yet
entered the the collective consciousness
so
you can imagine imagine that
we're all living on an island and many
of us are in the center of the island
far enough away so that maybe we can't
even see the shoreline and we can't see
the ocean that's that's where our
borders end but we're distant from the
artists are right on the edge
and they're they're they're
they're
they're expanding the landscape they're
they're they're moving the culture
forward that's where my metaphor fails i
guess um they're moving the culture
forward into the unknown and they do
that by translating what is as of yet
unimaginable but sensed into what is at
least imaginable
and represented represented in image and
and drama and literature and that's the
precursor to its full formulation in
articulated philosophy and thought and
that's what artists do they're problem
solvers they're problem detectors and
problem solvers that's what true artists
do and they're always trying to solve
problems like if you there's a great
documentary that was made about picasso
for example uh painting unfortunately i
can't remember the name of it i think it
was made in 1957 it's available on
youtube and it's in black and white and
picasso
is filmed making a painting on a on a on
a window so that you can see exactly
what it's doing and you can watch him
work with ideas he he paints something
in and then he erases it and you know he
paints over it and then he paints again
and he paints over he moves the figures
around on the canvas it's a window pane
as i said and you can see him working
out
visual
you can see him working out
problems and solutions to problems using
using his visual imagination and the the
artistic product the painting is is the
consequence of that rather than the aim
of it the aim is to formulate the
problems and to work out the solutions
and the artistic
uh product the painting is is the
byproduct of that not the aim
and so artists move us forward into the
unknown and you can see them doing that
in cities because it's the open people
the artists who go into parts of the
cities that are have degenerated to some
degree back into chaos and then
revitalize them and they civilize them
and then the less artistic people who
who are more conventional move in and
you know that's when you get
gentrification and that sort of thing
and that usually chases the artists out
and they go somewhere else cheap and
interesting and start the renewal
process again so the thing about artists
and and it's a hard thing to balance
properly in our culture is that artists
are unbelievably productive economically
but it's very very hard for them to
monetize their productivity so even
though what they produce can be of
incalculable value
it's very difficult for them to get any
of the economic value that they're
produced actually directed towards them
it's a major problem in in it's a major
problem with trade openness as a mode of
being in the world
so
is post-modernism as destructive in this
realm as it is in politics
post-modernism is perhaps equally
destructive in all realms as far as i
can tell especially when it's alive but
with neo-marxism and those two things
there's no reason they should go hand in
hand you know because if you're a
post-modernist there's absolutely no
reason stemming from your own philosophy
that you should ally yourself with a new
marxist political outlook and the fact
that those two things are found together
almost inevitably indicates to me that
postmodernism is the handmaiden of the
neo-marxists rather than the other way
around
so in in fact post-modernism is the
intellectual front that the neo-marxists
wear
or adopt to hide from themselves and
other people their true motivations
which are mostly
driven by revenge and and resentment and
the desire to destroy and a hatred for
quality and a hatred for qualitative
distinctions which is dead it's death i
mean with young people you want to say
look there's not much to you're only 20
and you're kind of useless
but that's because you're only 20. you
know it's that doesn't mean you're not
full of potential that potential needs
to manifest itself so that you can turn
into something that's that's of of like
of world-beating significance but in
order to tell a young person that
credibly you have to say look there are
true qualitative distinctions between
things and you're just getting started
there are heights that you can ascend to
that are genuinely high which also means
they're above where you are now but that
gives your life the fact that there are
those things to pursue gives your life
deep meaning and significance and gives
your struggle
nobility and validity and the
post-modernist neil marxist as far as
i'm concerned are absolute enemies of
qualitative distinctions and so what
they do is destroy everyone's ambition
it's like we're all already as valuable
as we're going to get it's like okay
well fine that's good we don't have to
feel bad about ourselves but what the
hell are we going to do what are we
going to orient ourselves towards
what we want is multiple hierarchies
multiple steep hierarchies of competence
that are open in in fair competition to
everyone and and if we don't have enough
hierarchies of competence for everyone
then you know it's up to the creative
people to produce some new ones it's not
like we'll necessarily run out
so
all right
have you ever had to tell someone that
they are best suited to a subservient
slash blue collar lifestyle because they
don't have any semblance of brilliance
okay well i want to take issue with the
formulation of that question although i
think it's a perfectly reasonable
question that's jan swann
don't be thinking that a blue-collar
lifestyle is necessarily subservient i
mean first of all you can be a trades
person and that's a really good career
choice as far as i'm concerned it's it's
very very valuable i mean you know good
plumbers are rare and good carpenters
are rare and good brick layers are rare
and they're so useful i mean i do a lot
of renovation work i've done an awful
lot of renovation work on all the places
that i've i've lived in and i've learned
to do a fair bit of construction and
automotive bodywork and all those sorts
of things and i really like doing it and
you know there's their blue collar life
is not necessarily subservient at all
because you can be master of your trades
domain and be unbelievably economically
useful and productive and creative and
independent and autonomous and so
there's there's nothing necessarily
subservient about that
um
now you know if you're thinking more
about about let's say life at the low
end of a restaurant but even there if
you're a conscientious person and you're
careful and you and you're awake and you
treat the people around you well and you
do your job properly there's also room
for advancement in the private sphere
there's no reason to assume whatsoever
that merely because you don't have the
intellectual horsepower to work well in
the abs in the in the domain of rapidly
shifting abstractions that your life has
to be of secondary quality or
or or opportunity i don't see that at
all and and there is endless opportunity
in the trades and and like in in toronto
for example there's a chronic shortage
of tradespeople and there's always a
shortage of qualified people for every
occupation so um
if i have to tell someone that they're
best suited to a blue collar lifestyle i
wouldn't feel bad about it i might say
to them well look you know um you you
know let's assume you're talking to
someone who has an iq of 100 which is
the iq of the average high school
graduate you might say well look you
know
unless you're super conscientious
uh uh career in something like law is
probably not your best bet because
you're going to be competing with people
who have iqs that are like 30 points
higher than yours or 25 points higher
than yours and if you really work
yourself to death you might be able to
maintain competitiveness in that domain
but you're going to be working at a
powerful disadvantage because the people
that you're competing with for example
are going to be way faster than you
verbally they're going to be able to
read faster and to reason verbally
faster and and all of that and it might
be better to pick up
an ambition that's more in keeping with
the quality of your temperament and your
intelligence to to put it bluntly so
that you can be but that doesn't mean
that your success has to be limited and
it also doesn't mean that i'm in
elevating intelligence to to a platform
of the ultimate moral ideal because the
relationship between intelligence and
moral ideal is zero there's no
relationship between them at all
intelligence is a is a capacity let's
say that can be put to
ill use just as well as to good use and
there's nothing intrinsically better
about smart people they might be more
useful for certain things if they're
oriented towards the good
but
um there's absolutely there's no
shortage of opportunity in the working
class end of the
end of the world and i can certainly
understand often why people might prefer
that to to
the
endless my asthma you might say chaotic
my asthma of complex abstract jobs one
of the problems with those sorts of jobs
is that you're never done you never
finish there's always more work than you
can possibly do
so
all right so that's a good one let's see
here
um
i feel sensitive to meme culture
irony
it seems hard to act out honesty when
every facet of human behavior has turned
into a meme so i worry people's natural
reaction will be to mock or scoff well
you know i've been the target of my fair
share of memes
perhaps more than my fair share and i
actually find it extremely i'm really
happy about it and part of the reason
for that
involves some of the elements of our
earlier discussion people were saying
well how do you plan to keep your feet
on the ground say given your new found
public
profile and i see the the meme culture
as
part of the corrective i mean there's a
great role for satire and irony and all
of the elements of comedy to to act as a
corrective
and i mean i've been fortunate because
most of the memes that have been
directed my way have been
done with good humor i'm lucky because
for some reason
the
ratio of positive attention i
received from the general public let's
say
is
compared to the ratio to the amount of
negative
uh reactions i'm receiving is very
disproportionate i'm receiving almost
all positive reactions so you know i'm
in the fortunate position of being able
to laugh along with it but
um
i don't think that there's any reason to
assume that irony and satire have to
become cruel and scoffing
they they can be done with a light touch
and they can be done in a manner that
keeps everybody awake
and make sure that no one is above
both criticism and and and humor
that they're
now
that sort of thing can become cynical
very rapidly but it degenerates as soon
as it becomes cynical you see this with
satirical shows you know like i really
like the simpsons the first 13 seasons
in particular and like it it was one of
the very rare true satires on american
television and it never degenerated into
cynicism in part because
although it
comedically critiqued almost every
element of american life it was also it
also had a set of messages that were
very positive so for example the simpson
family was an extraordinarily coherent
nuclear family unit and for whatever
homer's faults might have been and they
were myriad he was always there as a
reliable and trustworthy uh father to
his family despite his you know somewhat
limited abilities both ethically and
intellectually he was there when it
counted and that stopped that show from
degenerating into cynicism and i also
think the same about the trailer park
boys which is a show that i have a fair
bit of partiality for despite its its
endless profanity and and and absurdity
it has the same underlying structure is
that the characters are bound together
by genuine affection and there's
something about that that that makes the
satirical message
both positive and deeply acceptable as
far as i'm concerned so
i know lots of laughs jordan watches
trailer park boys i don't just watch it
i really like it i really get a kick out
of it i don't know how many of you are
trailer park boys aficionados probably
not that many because it is a pretty
rough show but um the conkey episode
that's going to be one of them
the high that's one of the highest
that's the the highest reach of canadian
comedy as far as i'm concerned that
episode just absolutely floored me it
was so it was so surreal and so absurd
that
all right let's see here
what is your advice for someone who
lives with chronic pain
wow that's a tough one how can i
discipline myself mentally in order to
be productive when i feel awful all of
the time
what coping methods can i use look the
first thing i would say this is a
question posed by shivers is like if
you're suffering chronic pain one of the
things you can do is try not to judge
yourself too harshly man that's really
rough and
why don't you start by assuming that if
you're having a hard time disciplining
yourself that it's actually a
consequence of the chronic pain rather
than a moral fault you know like i've
dealt with lots of people who've had
terrible chronic health problems and
you know you you you want to
push yourself because you don't want to
end up in a situation where
the disease condition is taking more
away from you than it absolutely has to
so you attempt to impose minimal
disciplinary structures on yourself to
to push the illness back as much as you
can but if you're in chronic pain i
would say um
you need to find someone that you can
trust to talk to so that they can help
you plan
and you need to be able to delineate out
what your limitations are in a manner
that they can understand so that you can
jointly focus on
how to make productive use and high
quality use of the time that you can
actually spend
outside of merely suffering the other
thing that i would ask you about is are
you sure that your medication regime
regimen is adjusted optimally because
antidepressants for example can be very
effective long-term
medication for chronic pain especially
uh drugs like celexa which so i don't
know if you use an antidepressant in
your attempts to manage your chronic
pain but that's something i would
definitely recommend and there's a lot
of pharmaceutical
treatment and you know you may have run
the gamut already i know lots of people
who have chronic pain have done that but
and also stimulants like the adhd
medications um can also be helpful in
the management of pain because stimulant
medication
um
has an analgesic properties so you might
want to consult a number of specialists
about your medication regimen to see
that you're medicated to the optimal
degree but i would definitely recommend
antidepressants and also
find and and talking to someone find
someone you can trust so that you can
talk to them about your genuine
limitations and how you might transcend
them and and also see if you can not
torture yourself with guilt because you
aren't able to live
the productive life that someone who's
free of chronic pain might i mean it can
be unbelievably debilitating so mostly
uh
well so i'm very sorry to hear that
that's plaguing you and and uh
when you say how can i discipline myself
i'm sorry i'm i'm afraid i've lost the
question you said how can i discipline
myself at something like how can i
discipline myself when i'm in in chronic
pain it's like well
i think
the a more appropriate question might be
how can you ensure you that you treat
yourself with the appropriate compassion
if you happen to be living with severe
chronic pain and maybe the disciplinary
element should be secondary it's
something like that
so
i'm getting tired guys so i'm probably
gonna stop at nine i'm gonna stop at 9
30 because i'm gonna start becoming
incoherent if i don't so just to give
you a warning we're gonna we're gonna
run this for 15 more minutes so
is joining the military a respectable
path for my life
well i would say it would likely depend
on how you conduct yourself as a soldier
it and also what your alternatives are
but i wouldn't so i wouldn't say yes
without reservation but i certainly
wouldn't say no without reservation i
think joining the military can be a a
respectable pathway for your life i mean
it's obviously a complex pathway but um
it's not like the military isn't a
necessity and so if there's something in
you that tilts you in that direction
then
um perhaps that's courage in you talking
that's certainly possible so
um
let's see
let's go back to the pigeonhole thing
here
becoming a truthful person involves
dealing with the guilt of past lies is
it better to come clean about old lies
even if they will ruin lives or forgive
yourself and focus on living truthfully
in the present and future ah
that's a that's a really good question
um
i would say that there
there are
telling the truth doesn't mean
saying everything about everything all
the time it's a lot more complicated
than that first of all you have a right
to privacy and second like here's an
example this is a tricky one but i think
it would address
your question
imagine that you've had an affair you
have a happy marriage but you had an
affair and maybe you had an affair three
years ago and maybe it was you know a
couple of weeks or a couple of months or
maybe it was even only one night and
it's driving you crazy you're guilty
about it and you feel that you should
confess and i would say well the first
question is
have you learned your lesson
and the lesson should be
you've processed what you've done and
decreased the probability that you will
do it again to something as closely
approximating 0 as possible
and then you have to ask yourself what
makes you think that you have any right
to confess
because then what you would do is take
the original transgression which was
quite severe and
hurt someone very badly by revealing it
and you might say well you pat yourself
on the back for being a truthful person
about it but i would say you've already
sacrificed the right you have
to be truthful about that
and and i know i'm oversimplifying it
because the only way to not oversimplify
such a thing is to use a real example
and not a hypothetical example but i
think many times
the moral thing to do is to take your
guilty secrets to the grave
and
maybe you can talk about them with a
therapist or you can talk about them
with someone that you really trust
who'll maintain confidentiality but um
you don't come clean about old lives
you're not coming clean about old lies
generally if that will ruin lives
and i don't think you you forgive
yourself precisely and focus on living
truthfully in the future you focus on
living truthfully in the future and
perhaps you don't forgive yourself
exactly that doesn't mean you pound
yourself into the ground with guilt but
if you have done things in the past that
were reprehensible and that would
destroy lives if we're brought to light
then
you should
i think that generally speaking you
should do everything you can to limit
the spread of damage as you attempt to
move truthfully into the future
so
you've said that a marriage must be
based on trust and transparency and
being shackled together how and for how
long should you get to know someone how
to set a foundation oh well you know
there's no
there's no simple answer to that
um i think that you should
know someone well enough
so that you can
so that you know if you can negotiate
with them and so that you have started
to formulate a vision of your joint
future that you can both
look forward to with enthusiasm and
confidence
so and of course that's going to depend
to some degree on your level of maturity
but that means
you've considered such things as
do you have a sufficient number of joint
interests and are you oriented in the
same direction with regards to how
you're going to handle your joint
careers and the possibility of children
and the the manner in which you're going
to interact with your in-laws and you
you have to start thinking about you
have to start
considering your life together from the
perspective of practicality and
economics i would say so it can't just
be that massive erotic attraction that's
associated with
with love although i think that's
extraordinarily important and you're
unbelievably fortunate if you have that
and you should do everything you can to
maintain it which and that takes effort
that takes real effort and will but
you need to ally that with with maturity
and intelligence and the maturity and
intelligence is okay we're going to put
our lives together what's that going to
look like at the level of detail how are
we going to handle our finances where
are we going to live
what are our joint plans going to be et
cetera one of the things that my
business partners and i plan to do
in
what would you say that in uh
as an analog to the self-authoring suite
is that we want to develop
an online program to help people
negotiate their relationships
and and so it would actually provide an
answer to this question in a more
comprehensive manner is that
imagine that if you want to set up a
household with someone
then there's a lot of things that you
need to get straight and you either do
that by bringing your unconscious
assumptions to bear on the situation and
perhaps clashing where they don't
match or you sit down like a conscious
and aware and articulate couple and
start to negotiate what your joint
responsibilities are going to be and so
that would be well um
who's responsible for the meals and when
and what are you going to eat and who's
going to get groceries and who's going
to pay the bills and who's going to do
which part of what household chores
there are to do and how is that going to
be laid out fair and so you should get
to know
you should get to know the person that
you're with well enough so that you can
start discussing the real practical
issues of life and determine whether or
not you're capable of of negotiating
that and i don't think that necessarily
means that you should live together
because the evidence is actually quite
strong at least the last time i looked
that people who live together are more
rather than less likely to be divorced
now that might be that might have
nothing to do with the actual act of
living together it might be that people
who are more likely to get divorced are
also those who are more likely to merely
live together but i don't think that's a
great solution for reasons i won't get
go get into now and with regards to
being shackled together is that that's a
complicated one and and i learned this
at least in part from reading carl jung
and the idea there is that
unless you've really made a commitment
to someone like a lifetime commitment
and that that's a serious commitment one
that you're not going to back out of
you're not going to take the
relationship with the seriousness that's
necessary to make it
of the highest possible quality and
sustainability across the course of your
life
and it's really important that it is of
that high quality and sustainability
because the relationship especially when
it starts to produce children is a
machine let's say a machine that you
jointly operate that adds immensely to
the quality of your life and the depth
of your life i mean you you have the
rope and strand of your life and your
partner has the strands and the rope of
his or her life and then those are tied
together to make a stronger rope and
then that unites you across time and
then you undertake massive adventures
together and some of that is the
establishment of a household and the
establishment of joint careers and the
maintenance of each other's mental and
physical health and the maintenance of a
high quality sexual life and all of that
very very challenging to do all of that
and then the joint
production and and care of children
which which sets you up properly for the
last half of your life so like i'm 55
now you know and
both my kids just got engaged in the
last month so that's pretty bloody
amazing and they're both setting up
households and um
and they're stepping into adulthood and
i'm fortunate enough to have them in the
city that i live in so hooray for me
that's so bloody uh
fortunate that i can hardly believe it i
mean we've helped them out and tried to
make it
um
what would you say
to make the possibility of their living
here be something that's viable but i'm
absolutely thrilled that they're going
to be around and i'm looking forward
immensely to having grandchildren and
like what else are you going to do when
you're
55 you know and you're going to be 55
it's going to i might have 40 more years
like what am i going to do with those
years
well so i have a good marriage thank god
for that and that's partly due to the
outstanding moral quality of my life my
wife who i'm also extraordinarily
attracted to
and uh you know we've built a life
together and we've had kids together and
we're happy with our kids and we had
plenty of struggle with our kids because
one of our children my daughter had
serious serious health problems which
she seems to have managed to resolve
partly as a consequence of her own
brilliance
but
you know we've set ourselves up now so
that our children are respectable and
mature young adults so thank god for
that and they've got partners who we
both really like and they're gonna have
children and
well hooray you know that means that
this next part of my life is going to be
something that i can advance into with a
with a fair bit of hope and and and
excitement and the idea of having little
kids around again is thrilling because i
really like little kids they're really
really fun
and so
the the shackle together is more like
it's a it's it's it's such a i may have
even said that but it's such a cynical
way of looking at it it's more like what
you've produced is an unbreakable bond
between two beings and that that makes
both of them both of them better in
every way if it's based on if it's a
relationship that's based on trust and
genuine communication that's very
difficult thing to attain
because you have to be willing to tell
the truth and the truth is they're
generally a horrible thing you know i
mean it's easy to tell truth when
everyone wants to hear what you have to
say but it's very difficult to tell the
truth when no one wants to hear it least
of all yourself
and so marriage gets a very bad rap in
our culture and so does
child-rearing and i think that's
absolute catastrophe because
really
being in a long-term relationship a
marriage let's say
and having children that's two-thirds of
your life even if you're a highly
career-oriented person that's two-thirds
of your life and i'm a highly
career-oriented person and
my family has been unbelievably
important to me and has also been
something that's enabled me to be very
effective in my career because my house
has been a sanctuary for me and thank
god for that especially over well many
times in my life but especially over the
last year
so
you should you should get to know
someone long enough to know that you too
can
go tell the truth with each other
communicate and negotiate because the
most important part of a relationship is
the fact that you can tell each other
the truth and negotiate
so
how does it feel to be viewed as a
father figure by many people who grew up
without one well i think it's an
unbelievable honor how's that and that
is really what i think i think it's a
tremendous honor and i'm doing
absolutely everything i can to be worthy
of that and i would like to say to all
the people out there who grew up without
a father that's really too bad because
you need a father there to encourage you
that's what fathers do is they encourage
they help
make you courageous and if i can help
people
develop the capacity to be courageous
and to learn to tell the truth and to be
responsible then that's great i
i can't imagine a better outcome for me
and so if people are willing to help me
play that role and to use what i've been
teaching to guide them in that manner
then hooray i couldn't possibly imagine
a better outcome than that
so
how do you formulate good questions
giving that a well given that a
well-oriented question seems often more
critical than the answer that's a great
question by the way
a lot of what you do to formulate good
questions is listen
like if you're
engaged in dialogue with someone and you
really listen to what they're saying
the all you have to do is notice when
you don't understand what they're saying
and then ask them for a clarification
and that's the case when you're dealing
with the the factual world as well you
know um
what you do to formulate good questions
is admit your own ignorance to yourself
and then try to articulate that
ignorance as clearly and simply as you
possibly can
and so i do that all the time when i'm
in my clinical sessions with people
because they'll be telling me the story
of their life
years ago perhaps or maybe events over
the last few weeks or whatever and
they'll tell me the story and and i'll
detect
elements of it that i don't understand
or that are unclear or that seems
self-contradictory and so then i'll just
ask it says well i don't i don't
understand what you're saying there you
said this as far as i can tell but that
wasn't clear what exactly do you mean
and so a huge and and get them to
articulate it and and maybe i'll say
well you said this now but you said this
you know 10 minutes ago and as far as i
can tell those two things are opposites
and so how do you how do you uh bridge
the gap between those things and but the
critical issue with regards to good
questions is that you admit to yourself
your own ignorance and you're not
embarrassed about it like there's
nothing wrong with being ignorant well
that's not true it's a terrible thing to
be ignorant but it's inevitable
but it's not a moral flaw
it's just unfortunate the moral flaw is
in refusing to admit to it and so
you know
the students who do really well in
classes are the ones who ask basic
questions they put up their hand and say
look you know everyone else here seems
to understand this but this is a point
that i really don't get and you know
rarely a person asks a question like
that and they haven't been listening and
they haven't been paying attention and
they're just being annoying but most of
the time
people who do that have been paying
attention and they're asking a question
that everyone else in the room would
also like to ask but is embarrassed to
do so
so
um
all right
you said that positive emotion comes
from moving towards a goal but also that
friends and family are crucial to a
fulfilling life are both of these
hitting the same neural circuits i would
say no not precisely the the positive
emotion that comes from moving towards a
goal looks to me to be primarily
dopaminergic
and the the positive emotion that's
associated with friends and family i
think is much more associated with the
opiate system and some of the best work
on that was done by jacques pancep j a a
k
pancep
p-a-n-k-s-e-p-p and he wrote a book
called affective neuroscience and a
variety of very very good scientific
papers and laid some of the initial
groundwork for understanding the
relationship between the functioning of
the endogenous opiate systems and social
bonding so no i don't think they're the
same they share overlap because the
opiate circuits
can activate the dopaminergic circuits
um but
but there there are definite differences
in the system that that that seeks out
goals and that's the system that pancep
actually called the seeking system
that's the dopaminergic system and the
more affiliative systems so they're
definitely overlapping but separate
neural circuits and so
um
not to take away from your
interpretations but for a skeptic how do
you know that your analysis of biblical
stories are true well that's a great
question but the issue there is what
what do you mean by true
i would say they're functional because
i'm a pragmatist and i mean that
technically i believe that our
conceptual structures are tools to help
us orient ourselves in the world and so
the issue for me is are the
interpretations that i'm making of the
biblical stories
useful functional tools for people to
use to operate in the world
and how can i demonstrate that they're
canonical interpretations of the bible
well i can't demonstrate that what i can
say is that people can listen to them
and make their own judgment about
whether or not they're
useful and valid which i think is a
better way of thinking about it than
than true because
truth in literature and mythology is a
very tricky concept and especially in a
book like the bible which as i pointed
out in the first biblical lecture is the
first truly hyperlinked text where every
almost every verse interacts with almost
every other verse and so
it's an end it's endlessly deep and
there's an endless number in some sense
of valid interpretations that could come
forth from it but
um
there's more to the answer to that
question but i can't go into it for now
because i'm well we're running out of
time and i'm running out of energy in
fact it is 9 30 and so um
and so and my daughter has just showed
up and my wife has told me that so i
think i'm actually going to take this
opportunity to bow out and to say once
again thank you um this is my wife by
the way you might as well
i was watching the video and i thought
she was still in the room the videos
lagged so um i was actually interacting
with a ghost there for a minute um
i wanted to thank you all again for
supporting me um i also want to say i
know that for you patreons that have
been
supporting me to the
for at the 200 level i know that i
promise to give you producer credit on
the um biblical videos and i haven't
forgotten that i just haven't done it
yet because i would like to say because
i've been doing a bunch of other things
and i do actually believe that's true
but i haven't forgotten and i still want
to do it and i think it is important and
you have been crucial to the production
of these this series all of you patreon
supporters and i'm hoping that i can
continue to put the support that you've
been offering me to to ever better use
and hopefully you can also help guide me
in doing that in these q and a's because
it gives us a chance to uh
to communicate so um
well so i'm gonna say good night and uh
thanks a lot to all of you and we'll see
you in a month
um
get your act together all of you and and
do what you can man it'd be a wonderful
thing to see and if enough people start
doing that maybe we can turn this whole
mess around that'd be lovely and maybe
it won't take that many people to start
it so that'd be a good goal
so
good night